my life is fueled by my being yeah
and the being fuels to doing so I come
from a centered place I come from a
focused place I come from compassion
it's just it's just my nature
I come from a willingness to understand
and to be understood and I come from
wanting to to to connect I mean the
secret of that show for 25 years is that
people could see themselves in me all
over the world they could see themselves
in me and even as I became more and more
financially successful which was a big
surprise to me I was like oh my god this
is so exciting I mean you got more than
that 30,000 more than 30,000 by the time
I was 30 so so my but what what I
realized is through the whole process
because I'm grounded in my own self that
although I could have more shoes my feet
stayed on the ground although I was
wearing better shoes he's kind of cute
today too so I could keep my feet on the
ground even though I could get more
shoes and I could understand I could
understand that it really was because I
was grounded I've done the was doing and
continue to this day to do the
consciousness work I work at staying
awake and being awakened is just another
word for spirituality but spirituality
throws people off and they think you
being religion when I was hiring people
for my company for own of looking for
presidents when people would come in I'd
say tell me what is your spiritual
practice and literally would throat
people go well the puts are I well I'm
not religious or I said I didn't ask you
about your religion I asked you what
your spiritual practice what do you do
to take care of yourself what do you do
to keep yourself
centered what do you do to the and uh
you know one women started crying you
know that's not the person that's the
thing that's a sign so so to answer your
question everything is fueled that comes
from me really wanting to be a better
person on earth and this is what I know
to be true the reason why the show
worked is because I understood that that
audience my viewers the people who
watched us every day and would come and
just like you all did get tickets and
they would come with their fight you all
just came across campus but that's good
too but people would come from all over
the world just to be there with their
aunts and their mothers and they come
with their cousins and there'd be a few
men and they're going what the Hill or
saying well I went to Oprah with you I
went to Oprah well at least give me
clear for three or four weeks I went to
over with you I had such regard for that
and I just had a conversation with John
Mackey who runs Whole Foods yet and has
written this fabulous book you should
get it called conscious capitalism and
he was talking about how the investment
in the stakeholders the people who you
are serving that connection between the
people who you're trying to serve and
sell to is equally as important as the
people who you're buying from equally as
important as the people who are you know
supporting you financially as your
stockholders if you are you know you
know a public company so I always
understood that there really was no
difference between me in the audience at
times I might have had better shoes but
at the core the core of what really
matters that we are the same you know
how I know that because all of us are
seeking the same thing you're here at
this fabulous school and we'll go out
into the world and each pursue based
upon what you believe your talents are
what your skills are maybe your gifts
are
but you're seeking the same thing
everybody wants to fulfill the highest
truest expression of yourself as a human
being that's what you're looking for the
highest truest expression of yourself as
a human being and because I understand
that I understand that if you're working
in a bakery and that's where you want to
be and that may be that may be what
you've always wanted to do is to bake
pies for people or bake cakes for people
or to offer your gift then then that's
that's for you and there's no difference
between you and me except that's how
that's your platform that's your show
every day so my understanding of that
has allowed me to have a line to reach
everyone and and there's no way that you
wouldn't because that's that's what I
truly feel